rires pour oublier
rires pour se retrouver ou rire tout
simplement pour exister
l'atelier yoga du rire fait partie des
ateliers bien-être te permettent aux
aidants de s'arrêter un moment et de
prendre soin de leur esprit de leur
corps nous sommes ici à la case
grand-air un site situé à l'antre-2
placé sous l'autorité du gip et à saper
maison de l'aide à la personne
anne marie danielle liliane et tous les
autres viennent pour certains la
première fois d'autres sont des habitués
deux fois par semaine tous s'accordent
un peu de répit
j'ai eu la dent dure avec vous ici quoi
me décontracter au maximum quelque chose
de luxueux presque inaccessible parce
qu'on a pas le temps parce que ça
demande un effort ou sa demande d'un
état d'esprit qu'on n'a pas on n'a pas
forcément l'énergie pour pour rallumer
cet état d'esprit cette petite cette
petite joie de vivre qui est là elle qui
dort une petite flamme qui a fini par
s'éteindre à jour donc bien sûr c'est
bénéfique pour tout le monde en général
et en particulier pour des personnes
sont dans des contextes difficiles et
qu'ils ont plus tendance à vivre dans la
souffrance dans la tristesse dans la
peur du lendemain que dans des choses
quinconces trous dans les projets qu'on
peut comprendre
à construire sa vie pour évoluer
donc oui c'est bénéfique fois que je
viens je suis venu en week-end c'était
super bien à une équipe vraiment très
qui nous encadrent beaucoup on peut dire
c'est la maison du bonheur pour faire
depuis le temps que je suis dans ce
schéma meilleur j'ai fait mon père à
marennes maintenant ma mère est ma tête
et s'est fait que nous laisse plus
beaucoup de temps le rire l'humeur
d'aujourd'hui qui parfois se transforme
en larmes car rien n'est facile quand on
se retrouve à s'occuper d'une maman d'un
mari d'une épouse d'un frère totalement
dépendant de l'autre c'est loin c'est
d'ailleurs ce que c'est depuis 3h du
matin par pc30 matin et c'est tout la
journée il y répète les mêmes choses il
veut toujours les mêmes choses et
c'est sans cesse penser ça c'était toute
la journée ils me laissent pas accomplir
la case grand-air propose ainsi toute
une palette de services aux aidants
familiaux
outre le bien-être par l'activité les
aidants peuvent également se relaxer
avec de la réflexologie plantaire ou
encore une pose de vernis prendre soin
de soi pour mieux s'occuper de son aider
dans leurs échanges avec les autres et
puis les séances à les éclats de rire et
tout ça monte parce qu'à chaque fois
fière d'aider des séances
en fin d'audience qui change
alors ça nous permet de nous éclater de
d'oublier cas secondaires grâce à ces
intervenants à ces psychologues disons
assez thérapeute en quelque sorte
eh bien ça nous aide comme vous par
exemple la réflexologie dont je parlais
l'autre fois le yoga on fait aussi du
yoga avec monsieur arme ou d'un glace et
c'est remarquable absolument ça nous
apporte beaucoup
ça nous a peut dire même transformé
littéralement l'un comme l'autre
absolument
la maison du bonheur s'est donné pour
objectif d'accompagner et de soutenir
les aidants de les valoriser dans leur
rôle quotidien maintenir leur bien-être
mais également maintenir leur moral en
leur permettant par exemple d'avoir une
consultation avec la psychologue du
conseil départemental
c'est important d'abord parce que
justement c'est une coupure ça leur
permet de sortir un petit peu de leur
enfermement
on a aussi entendu parler de prison soit
en prison soit entre quatre murs chez
moi donc d'abord un ca faire la coupure
se rendre compte effectivement se rendre
compte de leur rôle et que leur rôle
d'aidant ça n'est pas rien c'est quelque
chose de très lourd que même en général
les autres membres de la famille ne se
rendent pas compte
point c'est lourd et ensuite ce sont
aussi des personnes qui peuvent arriver
un état d'épuisement physique mais aussi
psychique surtout psychique et là on est
là nous pour les aider justement à
prendre conscience de l'état dans lequel
elles sont pas ce qu'elles s'en rendent
pas toujours compte et les remonter
ensuite petit à petit vers quelque chose
de plus énergique à un partage et une
convivialité comme ce repas autour de la
table un moment des changes pour mieux
se connaître des aidants aidés et c'est
un endroit donc où on a mis en place un
accueil en deux sessions une session
journée pour les personnes pour les
aidants et une session séjour et ça se
déroule donc deux semaines dans le mois
où on al cet accueil de public sur les
cessions la case compte erc propose
également des séjours en direction des
aidants puisque dans cette grande maison
des chambres sont mises à leur
disposition un séjour pour rompre avec
un quotidien difficile
passer du rire aux larmes et surtout ne
pas rester indifférent émotion à l'image
de sammy chan qui ne voulaient pas venir
et qui repartit sourire aux lèvres
prendre du temps pour soi pour mieux
prendre soin de l'autre la cadre interne
a fait sa philosophie une notion
d'humanité ou vraie leçon de vie et de
partage
la case compères offre plusieurs
services des ateliers d'information
droit aed santé les différentes
pathologies et leur évolution
l'ergonomie ans des ateliers informatifs
et informatif qui passe depuis
l'information en sur les dispositifs et
les droits des ateliers de développement
personnel initiation techniques de
bien-être relaxation corporelle chez
dessus au gua souci esthétique
réflexologie des visites culturelles des
balades des soirées musicales des
ateliers d'activités spécifiques
innovantes aidants aidés
l'art-thérapie des travaux pratiques et
d'en aider ça peut être au niveau de
l'initiation au niveau des des
techniques de bien-être
on a aussi de l'ago thérapeute un espace
d'écouté et des poings coudes pour les
aidants avec des entretiens les
infirmiers avec les assistances sociales
ou encore avec les psychologues pour
pouvoir bénéficier du dispositif
il faut donc appeler un numéro vert le 0
800 500 30 00 2 donc à la suite de cet
appel
une infirmière dont prendra contact avec
lits d'ems et deviendra fait donc une
évaluation et lui proposera donc des
prestations les plus adaptées à sa
situation